reunimos a siete cinturones negros
soy cinturón negro soy cinturón de
cinturón negro soy cinturón metro seis
cintas negras soy cinturón soy cinturón
negro
dos de ellos son impostores si el grupo
los descubre ambos obtendrán un premio
en efectivo
si uno de los impostores sobrevive se
llevará el premio completo
quién es el impostor
hagamos algo rápido y casual para
comenzar cuánto tiempo llevan entrenando
y que practican comencemos por aquí me
llama andrew llevo ocho años entrenando
a gota de cuando soy jessica también
practico té cuando desde hace unos diez
años son más mi nombre es kate hudson
llevo seis años entrenando en karate y
taekwondo me llamo victoria llevo más de
diez años entrenando y practico
kajukenbo vine aquí para representar
este estilo de arte marcial
adriana llevo 15 años practicando
taekwondo 3ª está mi nombre es keys y he
practicado hapkido por 9 años soy lento
incluso llevo 10 años practicando judith
son muchos hacen te colono
acerca de las artes marciales cuando era
niño jugaba mucho a las peleas tata tata
y eso un día parte la mesa y mi madre se
enfadó mucho dijo tenemos que sacar de
esa energía de adentro y el día
siguiente me escribió en un rollo de
taekwondo cuando estábamos en la fila
andrew hablaba para sí mismo y creo que
estaba concentrado porque no quería
equivocarse veía jackie chan cuando era
niña y decía quiero aprender karate
mi padre era cinturón negro y me enseñó
a los 5 años tú mi padre quiso que
aprendiera defensa propia mi padre
practicaba y cuido cuando era pequeña yo
quería ser como mi padre no quería que
fuese una bailarina y por eso me
inscribió en happy tomaba la mma y la
ufc quería entender las mejorías y
conocía el jiu jitsu
[Música]
creo que su historia fue muy específica
es algo que delata a las personas cuando
mienten
[Música]
siento que anthony actuaba sospechoso
por la forma en que dirigía la
conversación
[Música]
y luego les enseñaré mis movimientos
esta es la segunda ronda y será de artes
marciales cada uno tendrá cerca de 30
segundos para demostrar lo que sabe y
probarle a los demás que su cinturón
negro
no voy a arrojar la descuidada muy bien
muy bien
y
no no
pues
fue genial
eso fue terrible lo siento mejor
[Música]
y
su técnica parecía un poco básica pensé
que como a 7 cuando nos mostraría muchas
patadas y eso les enseñaré cómo lo hago
en mis clases ven aquí esto se llama
guardia en jiu jitsu es un arte marcial
que te enseña cómo atacar desde el suelo
esta es una estrangulación en triángulo
esta técnica se hace desde el cinturón
blanco hasta el negro nos enseñó un
movimiento de jujitsu que parecía
bastante ensayado era algo que cualquier
persona podría aprender sólo con ir a un
par de clases o entrenar un poco de jiu
jitsu y aseguró aquí y ahora paso mi
pierna alrededor de su cuello bajo su
cabeza y levanto las caderas y si no se
rinde se dormirá en seis segundos
o no
te amo
[Risas]
tú puedes
el cabello
muy bien
[Aplausos]
[Risas]
[Música]
muy bien
voy a comenzar
ah
[Música]
y
le cayó en el pie
[Aplausos]
aunque es muy impresionante tengo muchos
amigos que han aprendido de esos
movimientos incluso con sable y son
dobles de acción pero no cinturones
negros
hizo una demostración básica e incluso
aclaró que la técnica la usan todos
desde el cinturón blanco hasta el negro
demostró que sabéis jujitsu claro creo
que es un cinturón negro no
[Música]
aprobemos y
no lo sé quisiera tener su cabello si
todos están seguros de haber atrapado el
topo pueden terminar el juego ahora pero
si la mayoría tiene dudas el juego
continuará levanten la mano a los que
quieran continuar con el juego
amén
les tengo mucho respeto yo yo soy el
topo
no soy cinturón negro aún no pero quiero
serlo y no me siento bien engañando
ninguno de ustedes creo que son
fantásticas y no puedo mentirles no
puedo así que les pido disculpas
siento mucho haberlas engañado
no te disculpes lo es les quedan cuatro
minutos muy bien
bueno iba a proponer una demostración de
una pastilla que no hago eso creo que no
podría dar una patada la ctera como
parece es un arte de las artes marciales
tenía mis sospechas pero no quería
decirlo como algo malo sólo pensaba luce
tan nerd que me da la impresión de que
es un nuevo en esto en qué nivel estás
así que sin turbante listo conseguí mi
primer cinturón avanzado
en verano
entrené durante la pandemia empecé con
artes marciales en 2019 solía fumar y
beber desde joven y necesitaba cambiar
mi vida y
no no está bien tranquilo está bien
tranquilo
quería ser honesto
lo sentí aquí esto es divertido y no
quería solo ya saben está bien solo
rendirme
son tan buenas y me inspiran no puedo
mentir las personas que me inspiran
[Música]
e
lo siento adiós
repetimos había dos topos ahora levanten
la mano las que quieran continuar con el
juego
así a partir de ahora cada vez que todas
voten por alguien que no sea el topo el
dinero del premio se reducirá a la mitad
la única razón por la que quiero seguir
es que apenas mencioné lo de la patada
lateral tú me dijiste algo como hace
mucho tiempo que no hago eso no sé creo
que no podría dar una patada lateral tus
movimientos lucían como los de alguien
con un cinturón básico y algo cuando en
mi estudio soy segundo dan cuál era tu
estilo mi estilo o cielos la verdad es
que nunca me lo explicaron mi maestro
nunca fue el más profesional creo que
cuando victoria te pregunto cuál era tu
estilo tetas las que la responder porque
no es complicado yo hago hapkido un
cinturón negro puede explicar cómo dar
una patada lateral si es una empatada
básica lo es pero mis patadas nunca para
un mono no no importa la altura y
mientras vuelvas lar es memoria muscular
mira estafó buena
si en realidad todo complicado es
explicar la técnica de la ciudad la
saben porque he conocido a personas que
literalmente son ciegas tienen parálisis
o lo que sea y pueden enseñarte y
explicarte la técnica para ser honesto
ya quería eso así que no lo digo con la
intención de ofender mina class o lo que
sabes de lo que hablo son cosas huellas
que pensamos idiomas congelando esos
detalles y yo sólo creo que todas
ustedes son increíbles y pensé que
habíamos descubierto a andrey y aquí y
creí que ellos eran los topos no lo sé
que todos somos profesionales de algún
modo
si
no estoy muy segura sobre la técnica de
victoria porque no soy no tengo
conocimientos de eso
[Música]
me sentí mal porque atacamos a jessica
pero le pregunté cuál era su estilo de
artes marciales y titubeo no sabía y
pensé no estamos aquí por eso
lo siento está bien lo entiendo es un
juego está bien levanten la mano las que
quieran continuar con el juego
si las luces son verdes significa que
botaron al topo y ganaron si las luces
son rojas
significa que el topo si caen la caca y
perdieron
[Música]
un buen trabajo cinturones negros ahora
los dos cinturones negros falsos den un
paso adelante y muestren sen 3 2 1
[Música]
muy bien
rápido
mi padre era cinturón negro y cuando era
pequeño me inscribió en una escuela de
sherwood arkansas el dojo living defense
marc soler sedán y touring si yo
practico artes marciales soy autodidacta
con las armas practico muay thai también
y eso lo practico formalmente no importa
la edad que tengas tu tipo de cuerpo
cualquier persona puede convertirse en
cinturón negro si se esfuerza en ello
tuvieron un voto incorrecto así que
tomaré la mitad es una pena
[Aplausos]
buen trabajo bien hecho muy
buen trabajo
[Música]
[Risas]
[Aplausos]